Hayley look what I found on the hill my
guess is it's a animal bone and there
just happened to be some other animal
shot it yeah my mom thinking about
coming down I just need a break open the
tunnel didn't you see what options and
daddy sometimes mommies want daddies to
pitch in and if you don't mommy comes
after you and goes wrong so daddy is at
home doing his homework is very strange
we would start get ready we are gonna
have a fun Saturday night if I don't
need me any money moves all this and
then I found that well let's keep
digging we're gonna just sort of hang
here I'm in come on it's gonna be fun
I actually miss seeing you man it's
crazy having a kid no sleep no sleep no
sleep often there's a person I gotta
sleep you're just waiting to get my life
back when did it come back married
mm-hmm since one it's a license plate
wow this garbage in the ground if you
dig far enough you'll find al anthem Wow
I'm really nervous right now I don't
even know you that's very liberating
being in love what is that getting what
you want or is it giving somebody what
they want
you know yourself
what do you think is going on here you
don't want to dig i'll put some hookers
no no it's a sort of illogical John
Peters man pick up I don't eenie meenie
miney moe and flour bombs manuscripts
why are these books locked did you
unlock a book oh no sorry I'll put it
back where belongs look you're just
don't open it